hi this is international mastered square
ology in this chess comm lesson I'm
going to be talking about King position
feed a master in chess coach and Manuel
Neiman came up with seven signals that
let you know when to look for tactics
the first and most important signal is
King position all of these examples come
from the 2013 tromsø chess World Cup
this position comes from the classical
game between Vasily even Chuck and
Vladimir Kramnik Kramnik has a slight
advantage thanks to his outside posture
on a four but it shouldn't be enough to
win now one thing he does not want to do
is take on e5 because then he loses the
e4 pawn he loses his outside passer and
what results is a theoretical draw so
Kramnik instead played g6 to play King
g7 just to improve his King position
even if slightly white should play h3
and move the King back and forth or side
to side he can do that with the Queen as
well and that'll be enough for a draw
it's a possible way of playing but it's
enough for a draw
instead he played f4 and this week in
the King it might not look like it but
it does weaken the King and after a few
more moves even Chuck had add weaken the
King just too much now black has two
advantages the exposed King on g2 and
the outside passer on a for Yvonne sure
could have put up more resistance but I
can't really blame them when your King
is so exposed it's really hard to play
because you have to find the best
defensive moves it was only a matter of
time before kramnik found some way to
checkmate White's King with total
domination of the second rank White's
King had no chance of surviving with
that in mind here's a King position tip
exercise caution when moving pawns in
front of your king
this position comes from the rapid game
between laQuan Liam and Alexander Gris
Chuck white to play try to find the best
move ready
rook F for forking the king and the
knight fly has no choice but the take
and it's a draw by stalemate White's
King has no legal moose in the game
laQuan Liam did not find it
he played rook Abe and he still managed
to draw but he had to suffer a bit I
think the reason he didn't find it was
because his King his own king was
stalemated now usually when that happens
when your own king is stalemated that
means that your opponent is going to
have tactics in his favor so because
that happens so frequently white didn't
didn't think twice about looking for
tactics in his favor here's another tip
a stalemated King means look out for
tactics
this position comes from the Blitz game
between Yevgeny thomashefsky and
Alexander morozova ch White's
threatening Queen takes d5 and that
would fork the king and the rook so
black has to do something about his
bishop if he moves it back to c6 then he
loses d6 and he's probably going to lose
all of his king's head pawns and if he
takes on c4 then white gets the
initiative so in the game morozova CH
tried Queen e6 this is counterintuitive
because now the Queen is overloaded it's
defending d5 and d6 and after Bishop h3
it can't go back to f7 because then d6
falls so it almost looks like black is
losing because his queen is overloaded
and it's being attacked but morozova CH
finds a really nice resource he takes on
h3 and he allows white to fork him on d5
but he allows us because he's kept in
mind his opponent's weak King positioned
his White's King has become kind of weak
if white takes on a 8 then he's gonna
lose massive material because after rook
AJ he's now black is now threatening
checkmate white and after Queen b7 he
has to give up the Queen he has no other
way to avoid checkmate and then black is
able to go into an endgame where he's up
material and he still can start
advancing his pawns or he could go back
and continue to target White's King so
he's doing really well
in the game thomashefsky did not take
the rook on a eight instead he played
Knight d6 now if black plays rook h8
Queen f7 is bothersome
alright so in the game morozova CH ended
up losing I mean he ended up drawing and
then he was knocked out of the
tournament but still it was it was
amazing for him to keep the game alive
because it looked like he was in he
looked like he was in dire straits but
he still kept the game alive another
King position tip always keep your
opponent's king position in mind
this position comes from the classical
game between Alexander Shimon oov and
got a Kamsky White has a poor King
position and Black has he not only has
an attack but he has excellent alignment
in the game he played 9 g3 but he had a
better move you can pause it if you want
to try to find it ready
Queen h2 and if white takes then he gets
checkmated in short order and then if he
tries to run away black simply wins
material another King position tip look
for tactics when your opponent's king
position is weak
this position comes from the classical
game between chakra Mahmoud Yara and
gata Kamsky so it's White's turn and
White has a dangerous D pawn what he's
going to do is try to advance it and
black he's going to target White's core
king position because that's what he has
his compensation why has a dangerous D
pawn and black has a target in White's
King so white plays a sequence of moves
that makes a lot of sense he gets a
dangerous D pawn he starts advancing his
his main Trump in the position but black
goes for checkmate alright now here if
black takes the pawn which is
threatening to promote then he loses the
knight on e4 so it doesn't really make
sense to do that instead he plays rook
up - and threatens checkmate so white
has to respond and he does so by playing
Queen f2 which captures the rook and now
he goes into a position we arrive at a
position where y is upper rook he's up a
full rook but because his king position
is so bad black is able to find a way to
save the game
he plays Queen h4 and now he's
threatening some nasty discoveries with
Knight d3 followed by taking on c1 so
white has no choice but Smoove the king
this allows black to get some of his
material back and it's going to be
really easy for black to pick up the
rest of the pawns
here's another King position tip an
opponent's weak King position might give
you compensation
this next example is the most important
one white is David Navarro from Czech
Republic and black is young Ludwig
Hummer now blacks King position is a
little bit shaky a little bit because
white has an active queen a good
alignment he could think about playing
something like Queen h4 95 and queen h7
checkmate and he also has six which
sensitizes f7 and g6 and it would be
attacking the d7 nine so black has to
defend and this is why it's so important
because King position of course King
position is a signal that will let you
know that there's a tactic on board but
the the thing with King position is that
a lot of times you're going to have to
take on bad King position like young
Ludwig Hummer does in this position his
King is a little bit shaky it's not it
shouldn't be losing but I know that it
could maybe cause some uneasiness with
you if you're not used to defending
defending or if you don't like defending
so Hummer continues defending carefully
and now white white plays a very risky
move he goes for it
he just risks everything plays rook e1
and allows the fork knight h7 is a scary
move at first sight it's pretty scary
because Y has lots of pieces around
blacks King but it's not a sound
sacrifice first let's look at what
happens if he does take on h7
okay so night h7 queen g6 and after King
h8 he's going to get check mated rook
age for threatening rook h7 checkmate
and if black takes the rook on h4
then Queen g7 is checkmates the end of
the game and if he takes with the king
then white can play Knight f8 and he's
going to win the Queen due to the
discovery so taking on h7 is taboo but
black can play
nyeeehhh 6 he takes the knight and okay
so he takes all the material and then he
defends and this is fine a lot of your
games will be like this your opponent
will sacrifice will make an unsound
sacrifice to stalemate your king or put
your King in danger but it won't be
enough so really what you have to do and
in this position actually black has a
counter-attack he's threatening
checkmate the game didn't didn't last
long after Bishop b2 rookie six white
resign so the last King position tip
many of your opponent's are going to
attack you deal with it work on your
skills to find the best moves in both
offensive and defensive positions in
this chess comm lesson on King position
I gave you a lot of tips so let's review
them exercise caution when moving pawns
in front of your King a stalemated King
means look out for tactics always keep
your opponent's king position in mind
look for tactics when your opponent's
king position is weak an opponent's weak
King position might give you
compensation and last but definitely not
least many of your opponent's are going
to attack you deal with it learn how to
defend and there will be a reward for
you remember you can follow me on
twitter at scuola g bye guys